hi everyone sal here welcome to the
homeroom live stream we have a very
exciting guest today lori santos
professor at yale university who teaches
a class called psychology and the good
life so it's going to be a really
interesting conversation i encourage all
of you all to start putting questions on
the message boards on facebook and
youtube or wherever you're watching this
and the team will surface as many of
these as possible to myself and lori as
we get into the conversation before we
get into that i will give my standard
announcements a reminder that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
we can only exist through donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org
donate and making a donation i also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that have stepped up
especially during covid khan academy was
already running at the deficit
pre-covered our costs have gone up
dramatically
because our traffic has gone up
dramatically and we're trying to
accelerate a whole bunch of things to
keep everyone learning so special thanks
to bank of america google.org att fastly
novartis and many other supporters of
khan academy throughout the year
including many of y'all uh but we still
need more help especially we have a very
big gap still for 2021 so any help you
can provide is very very much
appreciated also want to remind everyone
about a homeroom
with sal the podcast
which is a flavor of what you're seeing
right now it's essentially episodes of
homeroom edited into a podcast format so
that you can enjoy it while also doing
things like safely driving or walking
so
or not being distracted by by my bizarre
face so encourage you to check that out
wherever you get your podcast so with
that i'm excited to introduce lori
santos lori thanks for joining us
thanks so much for having me on
so maybe a good place to start your
class
psychology and the good life like what
is what is that about why and why do you
feel that it needs to be taught
yeah yeah well the class really started
when i took on a new role at yale so i'm
a professor at yale i've been teaching
there for over a decade but in just the
last couple years i took on this new
role as a head of college on campus so
yale's one of these strange schools like
hogwarts and harry potter where there's
like these colleges within the college
um i'm head of silliman college but what
that means is that i live on campus with
students i'm like with them in the
trenches like eating with them in the
dining hall and hanging out and honestly
when i took on the new role i didn't
like what i was seeing i was seeing this
college student mental health crisis up
close and personal with so many students
being reporting feeling depressed and
anxious or just like stressed out about
life and fast forwarding you know i'd
have so many conversations where
students were like how's it going like
oh if i could just get through midterms
or oh if i could just like get to spring
break it was like not being present and
enjoying things and so it made me
realize that students just needed some
practical strategies for like how to
feel better in the modern day and age
and so the class really emerged out of
that it's a psychology class it's like a
lot of introductory psychology material
but it's all about the science of
well-being it's like evidence-based
strategies you can use to feel better
and the best part about the class is the
homework which wasn't the typical like
yale class homework it was homework like
meditate or make a new social connection
or savor your next eating experience it
was homework designed to put those
practices into effect and so you know i
put this class together like a normal
ivy league class just assuming you know
30 or 40 students would take it that's
pretty typical for a psychology class
here
it was a little astounded when over a
thousand students enrolled in the end we
had a quarter of the yale student body
tried to take the class which showed me
the students are voting with their feet
you know they don't like this culture of
feeling academically stressed and
overwhelmed all the time and i think
they really wanted some evidence-based
strategies they could use to feel better
now on one level what you just said is
surprising that it's so popular but on
another level it's it's so obvious that
it should be that way because what are
we doing anything for why are we even
living our lives if not to have a good
life to be happy and to be in the moment
and to be present so i i have a ton of
questions and already questions are
starting to come in
i'm curious two things uh one is do you
think that
things are different now than they were
when i think i i i look a lot older than
you when i was gonna say when you or i
went to school i i'm amazed to meet very
very accomplished professors who at
least look a lot younger than me but do
you think things are different than when
we went to school or generations past
and then what are um
what are the main tools that you're
trying to give folks to to help deal
with that
yeah yeah well there's some data on this
i mean the self-reported rates of mental
health issues have been skyrocketing
right and we could say that maybe that's
because there was more stigma to
admitting you were depressed or anxious
or something when we were in school but
those rates have been skyrocketing in
just the last five years right so i
don't think since 2016 the stigma has
gone down that much about saying i'm
feeling anxious or feeling depressed but
we're seeing things like in 2016 2016
that's not a short time period until now
you're seeing data
okay so sorry interrupted that's worth
no no it's crazy the rates are
skyrocketing since 2009 right just about
10 years double the rates of depression
in college-age students double right i
mean so these things are going up fast
the million-dollar question is why and
the honest answer is that we just don't
know there's probably a lot of factors
going on you know we're more socially
disconnected we're interacting more on
social media and technology
i think there's a lot more pressure on
students to go to a good school this
kind of meritocracy narrative has kind
of embedded all of our brains in a
different way than when we were in
school so lots of different factors but
what we know is like it is getting worse
and so we need some solutions and so
that gets to your next question which is
like okay what are the solutions what
are the you know what are the things we
can do and
one of the things the course teaches is
that we're all trying to be happier it's
not like people want to feel depressed
and anxious right the problem is that we
go about it the wrong way yeah we think
we need like the next accolade or we
need the next you know paycheck or we
need to change our circumstances and the
data just suggested that that is not the
path to higher well-being higher
well-being comes from our practices
a big thing is just social connection
you know
carving out time to spend with family
members and people you care about and
love
well-being comes from being other
oriented rather than selfish i think
there's this whole idea for students
nowadays that you got to focus on you
and your grades and your accolades and
your test scores but the data suggests
that happiness comes from focusing on
other people the happiest people out
there are people who do good for other
people and so one of the homework
assignments we give in my class is that
students have to do these random acts of
kindness and so you know just plug for
khan academy.org donate right one of the
leading predictors of happiness is if
you donate to good causes so you know
you can do something nice for khan
academy and boost your well-being um but
but then there's other just simple
things like healthy habits just
something as simple as sleep which we
know nowadays young people are doing
less of right the simple act of getting
seven to eight hours of sleep can
statistically boost your well-being um
you know people who are getting five
hours actually have mood levels that
look like they're clinically depressed
in part because they're not getting
enough sleep so the answers are really
simple in a funny way they almost seem
like kind of trite but actually none of
us are doing them right and so i think
seeing the science when you see a graph
that shows hey if you do random acts of
kindness here's your happiness versus if
you don't it's over here it's like oh
it's hard to argue with those data
first of all our philanthropy team
thanks you because i think we're going
to take that clip of what you just said
and actually i would love to see the
graphs too i'm already seeing our next
email ask for donations saying
we're going to do you a favor by
donating we're going to make you happier
and here's the empirical evidence why
that is true because that that feels
like a win-win um because you can
imagine uh
you know sometimes hard to ask for money
what's up but
he's like tip so many of these tips
actually have this win-win feature right
like by the act of doing something to
support yourself and your self-care
you're actually helping your community
you're helping the people around you and
we talk a lot about the evidence for
emotional contagion right like my
well-being is gonna affect the
well-being of people around me so by
like doing the right sorts of things for
yourself that's actually a way that you
can help your friends that's the way you
can help your family members like it's
putting your oxygen mask on first
doesn't just give you the oxygen it kind
of helps everybody around you too
laurie i'm not kidding i think you've
just defined our like winter giving
campaign like help yourself by helping
the children of the world
um but but going into i mean there's so
much that you said that i'd love to
impact you know there's already
questions coming in and i think this is
on a lot of folks's mind you know
nish786 on youtube saying
how can we
uh oh this is oh no this is selena chang
actually i'll get to nisha's question as
well you know what advice you have so
you're talking about you know taking up
time random acts of kindness getting
enough sleep being present
but you know the question here is how
you know students need to juggle
workload and other activities and stress
i think there's a lot of kids saying
that sounds nice but i got my
you know i got to prepare for the sat i
got this grade i got this project i got
to get my extra curriculars right i mean
right now we're in college admission
season uh for for you know the early
decision uh early decision just the
words have stress in it um right
you just what would you tell these folks
yeah yeah part of it part of it is part
of it is honestly getting your
priorities right it's recognizing that
you are not your grades right you are
not your accolades you are not what
happens on that early decision you know
that you will live and have a happy life
even if you don't get into your first
choice school or or worse the school
your parents think you need to go to
right like there are a lot of healthy
paths the other thing is that we know
that people who are feeling burnt out
you know if you're really in serious
mental health dysfunction like you're
not gonna be learning well right you
know when i look out at rates and
college rates of depression at places
like 40 of nationally college students
report being depressed over 60 report
feeling overwhelmingly anxious like
they're not learning the stuff i'm
teaching them right you you have to
support your mental health first and
then those academic achievements come
later this is the thing that's so
shocking to students but like the data
just bear this out in my class i teach
all about the evidence of sleep for for
improving grades right like just the
active sleep means you're gonna be more
likely to get higher grades and i have
students who are like okay it's midterm
season this feels really
counterintuitive to me normally i would
stay up like you know tons of hours and
not get any sleep but i'm gonna try it
and then they would come back to me
afterwards and report like you were
right like i did better on my midterms
this year than i have in years and i
feel better right because i'm not like
super sleep deprived and so
i think it's a matter of like overcoming
these misconceptions we have we think we
need to be on full throttle 100 of the
time and that's the way to get stuff
done but counter-intuitively focusing on
your well-being first might actually be
a way to make those grades that
accolades all that stuff easier and then
you get both for free
no i can't i can't reinforce more of
what you just said you know i had the
blessing of my first
job after business school i worked for a
small hedge fund in boston and uh my
boss who was actually a yale grad by the
way his name is dan wool and i remember
i was ready i was like i'm in a hedge
fund i'm gonna work 80 hours a week i'm
ready to just and i remember him telling
me after like the first week's excel why
are you here the market's closed go home
i was like okay dan i'm gonna go work
from home he's like no no sal our whole
job is to not make bad decisions and
make a few good decisions the best thing
you can do for your work
is to go home and live your life and not
think about work for the next whatever
12 hours or 16 hours and it was kind of
this mind-blowing thing to me but
he was right i mean he was a very
successful investor i learned a lot from
him it also created time and space for
me to do things like khan academy so i i
you know it completely resonates with
with what i what i've heard you know
actually 76 questions actually was very
similar to the previous question but
i'll ask it again because i think
we're i think you're chipping away at
what at people's
world view a little bit i'm sure you've
experienced this every every term that
you teach the class where people are
like okay maybe i could
sleep a little bit more maybe i could do
a few random accidents no but there's
still all the stress and i still have
all of this you know nisha's saying how
do you stay cool and content do you have
peer pressure you see other people doing
this you have uh all these
responsibilities and i think adults are
it's not just college students i think
adults are in the exact same boat
no totally i mean you know it was one of
the reasons my class went so viral right
was that yeah i was giving this stuff to
yale students but i got all these emails
like i'm 40. i'm 50. like i need these
tips too right i mean i think you know
we as adults don't necessarily know how
to do it and i think that's why there's
so much mental health dysfunction but i
think we've really gotten off track
right i mean i think one of the things
that's surprising is that the research
suggests that if you focus on happiness
first other good stuff will come right
we think we have to get the good stuff
first and then we can be happy we need
like perfect grades and get into the
perfect college and then i'll be happy
the data is funny it suggests the causal
arrow goes the opposite way there's data
for example that if you are in a
more positive mood that you're more
likely to find a creative solution to a
tough problem they did this study with
doctors who have a kind of like you know
house level medical diagnosis that's
really tricky if you're in a positive
mood you're more likely to see the
problem there's evidence suggesting that
your mood levels and your cheerfulness
levels at 18 actually predict how much
you're going to make when you're 30
years old right and so all of you
students out there who are making
yourselves miserable by not sleeping and
worrying about college turns out the
causal arrow might go the other way your
cheerfulness right now might be
predicting a whole host of stuff that's
going to affect your salary later on and
so i think it's a problem i think as a
society we really have it backwards we
actually need to be putting our oxygen
mask on first it doesn't just affect
like oh we feel good that feels nice it
affects the bottom line in a deep way
that's that's super powerful and there's
a bunch of questions there there are a
lot of the same flavor where i think
people are
they see the goal they've heard what you
just said i think you've you're
convincing them but you know from
facebook dolce castro garcia
currently i'm over stressing and feel
like i'm drowning in schoolwork how can
i deal with that in a healthy way that
allows me to keep working but not feel
like i can't breathe thanks i love the
science of well-being course youtube
casually obsessed says what is the best
way to reclaim your attention span i
think people are just looking for
yeah you know
baby steps yeah yeah yeah well a lot of
the practices that really help the good
news is they don't take a lot of time
and actually that's one of the other
tips is that a big predictor of people
feeling awful like like serious
depression is people's level of time
famine so this feeling that you're
really hungry for time you're just
frantic about time all the time and
what's amazing is that time fam and the
data suggest is going up even though our
free amount of time is actually going up
too it's like the perception that we're
so stressed for time is going up even as
we have more free time and so we don't
want to like take more time up or get
more stress like you don't want to get
all stressed out about like doing more
of these wellness activities right but
the good news is that a lot of them
don't take very much time right like you
can do a random act of kindness in two
minutes you know you could do a quick
five-minute meditation and just follow
your breath for five minutes you're not
gonna lose that much you know study time
if you take five minutes to do a
meditation and what you'll find is the
act of doing that is going to give you
back dividends in terms of your
attention and so on um so one of the
things i recommend is like especially in
this zoom time when we're all
experiencing so much zoom fatigue right
now is in between classes or in between
meetings just a three minute deep breath
meditation where you just breathe in
deeply into your ideally breathe into
your stomach so big stomach breath in
and then a really slow exhale and again
it sounds you know silly you know people
say like oh take a deep breath when
you're trying to be like all you know
worried about you being stressed and
things but
scientifically what happens is that that
deep breath activates your vagus nerve
and if you're taking a biology class on
khan academy you probably know that we
have this thing called the sympathetic
nervous system right that activates
that's our like fight-or-flight system
that's like oh gosh a tiger is coming or
an exam's coming i'm so freaked out what
you want to activate to decrease that
stress is your parasympathetic nervous
system the other part and you do that
through activation of the vagus nerve
right when you're taking those deep
breaths there's no tiger that could be
coming to get you and it just signals to
your body to kind of go back to that
de-stress mode and that takes like three
minutes and so you know that's one quick
tip that you can kind of build in
but another one is just like again it's
a broader more meta issue right one of
the reasons we're so stressed is that
we're going after the wrong stuff you
know what if everybody on this call
prioritize making a little bit more time
for the people they care about even if
it's just like 10 15 minutes a day you
know yeah you'll have less time for
school that's okay like the priority is
social connection that would pay huge
dividends where you're feeling a little
more socially connected you get a little
bit more laughter in your day like the
problem is that we have these priorities
that might not be getting us the things
we want including good grades you know
the best jobs afterwards and so on we
might be going about it the wrong way
no i i
that so resonates and you know i've
shared this on this live stream many
times i've become
a religious meditator i do it every day
half an hour and you're exactly right
it's very easy to rationalize that and
you don't have to do half an hour i
started doing 10 minutes a day but
you can rationalize oh i don't have time
for that half hour i gotta get the kids
ready i gotta you know have these
meetings etc but for me it's it's clear
causality that if i meditate i kind of
disassociate myself from all of these
made-up tigers in my head they're like
what are people going to think of me
what if that initiative khan academy
doesn't work what if we're not able to
raise enough money all of these tigers
that really aren't going to eat me um
and that frankly i forget the next week
uh but if i just take a i am i actually
view it as my 30 minute vacation i feel
like i'm on the beach even though it's
just in my head um
that you know marcus marcus really
aurelius the famous roman emperor in his
meditations he said you know people want
to always say they want to go to the
beach or get away from it all all you
have to do is go inward all you have to
do is realize that you can you can just
get away from it all if you kind of
separate yourself from your your your
identity your ego all of these things
that you identify with
and and i gotta say it it always works
it changes my mood i become more
affectionate to my wife i give her a hug
and a kiss i instead of trying to get my
kids out the door as fast as possible
i'm hugging them you know if there's
like daddy i'm late i'm like it's okay
you know and we're we're happier uh so i
i completely agree with what you're
saying are there other you know i i'd
love to you know from the science are
there things that surprised you things
that you're like wow yeah that's even
another data point that's so
counterintuitive or surprising
yeah i think another one that that
really surprised me is this the
importance of something like gratitude
right it sounds so cheesy like oh be
grateful like it's like some bad you
know social media thing that your
parents will share on facebook or
something like that but the data
suggests that like the act of
complaining which kind of feels good we
have this prediction that will feel nice
to gripe and complain with our friends
or or make memes complaining about stuff
and talking about how crappy everything
is like the data really suggests that
that's actually the opposite that taking
some time to count your blessings even
when things feel really bad even when
things feel really stressed is a way to
kind of give yourself a well-being boost
right there's data suggesting that the
simple act of scribbling down three to
five things you're grateful for every
day significantly boosts your happiness
in as little as two weeks but what's
more surprising is there's data
suggesting that experiencing gratitude
can actually bump up your willpower
right you know so some of you like have
to sit down and do that college
application or that like hard project
that you got to start work on and it
feels really tough you want the like
will power to sit there turns out what
gets you that gratitude the simple act
of like recognizing that you have
benefits in life makes you feel like you
know things are going pretty good i can
like i can do this thing that feels a
little hard and so again that feels so
totally counterintuitive to me you know
if you ask my brain what would feel
better like griping and complaining to
your friends or reading a lot of like
angry memes on reddit or something like
i'd be like that that's what my brain
thinks is gonna feel good but actually
what would feel better is you know to
text a friend of mine and say you know
hey i'm so great i don't say this often
but thanks for being there i'm really
grateful for you or to a parent or
something like that or even just
privately write down on like your phone
on some app the things that you really
love in life and the things that you're
really proud of like it sounds cheesy
but it really works
and that is so easy i mean you you
literally it takes seconds it just at
the moment when you see someone if you
appreciate them at all let them know
that you know all the questions that
have been coming in they're they're
they're all a lot of the same flavor i
mean what you've seen as a college head
um
just a lot of stressed out folks and i
think we're making headway in this
conversation my question is why is your
course kind of just like a one-off
course why shouldn't i mean to me this
feels obvious i've talked to other
university presidents professors
guidance counselors
this should be like more men your course
and not just your course but like the
practices you're describing it should be
like i don't know it feels like it
should just be part of the tissue of our
education system and probably work as
well
yeah i mean i agree completely we're
trying to get this content into as many
high schools right now as we can so if
you're a high school student and you
really want to see this content or if
you're an educator and you want to see
this content
let me know and then we'll really try to
get it in
you just drop me an email and i'll be
happy to send you more information um
but yeah i mean i think what's amusing
is that this stuff is needed to educate
students well right we simply are not
meeting our mission to teach students
computer science or math or chaucer with
40 of young people reporting that
they're too depressed to function most
days like the content is just not
getting in there and so i think we
really do need to think seriously about
whether or not educators need to be
building this kind of mental health
protective strategies into their content
that they're already developing
yeah and it's so simple i mean i'll stay
say what i'm getting from you
sleep meditation gratitude being present
all of those things i mean
you forgot the most important
random acts of kindness and donate to
god again oh yes and random acts of
kindness and donating to khan academy
yes maybe the most important one i'll
put it they're all they're all very
important you know where's your uh level
what are you looking into now what are
your areas of research what are what are
the questions you're trying to learn
more about
yeah well we're doing two things on on
the kind of publicizing side as i said
we're really trying to get this content
into as many schools and classrooms as
possible because i do think it i mean
the data really just suggests it just
makes completely a difference in terms
of boosting people's well-being but also
giving them the bandwidth you know to
achieve in other domains too um but
another thing i'm really struggling with
is is why this stuff is so hard right
like i'm i'm the professor that teaches
this stuff right i know the data it
should be really easy for me to meditate
all the time and do these random acts of
kindness and you know get enough sleep
and it's still hard for me and so i'm
really interested in this disconnect
between knowing what you should be doing
and actually putting it into practice
and so we're trying to come up with
different techniques we can use to nudge
people's behavior or that you can use to
nudge your own behavior in the right way
i think the next class that i teach at
yale will be about those kinds of things
all right now you know what you're
supposed to do all right let's actually
do it
and what what do you think is that what
is i mean you mentioned the sympathetic
parasympathetic which is yeah we we
humans maybe other animals do it too but
you know if there's a tiger yeah it
makes sense that your body goes into
overdrive you know all of your your
stress hormones get released and you
know blood flows to your muscle but then
we we have this chronic stress of like
oh i better do good in that thing three
weeks from now or i better raise enough
money for khan academy otherwise it'll
all
go away or you know and it's like you're
constantly being chased by a by
a tiger
why
what's going on in our heads is that
evolutionary favorable that's made us
plan and you know we're miserable but
we're able to make a more successful
society i mean why does that exist
yeah well natural selection is not about
us being happy natural selection just
wants to put our genes into the next
generation and i think you know that's
worth remembering that you're walking
around with this baggage in your head
that's that's not about your bandwidth
it's it's ready to push you you know to
the point to your breaking point right
and i think you know if you look at
evolution you see that there are these
you know like different rhodic creatures
who reproduce so much that they die in
one generation and i worry that this is
what we're pushing our students towards
right you know they they're at the
breaking point in terms of their mental
health to kind of achieve the kinds of
things we want them to achieve and i
think part of it is we need as a society
to kind of scale that back or else the
consequences are going to be really
steep but i think the beauty is that you
can even if you don't feel like your
school is doing that or your family's
doing that you can scale it back in your
own head through the kind of practices
we've been talking about you know even
just this idea of acceptance right you
know like your college admissions
process is going to be what it's gonna
be you've done your best can you just be
with that and accept that you know the
uncertainty of the modern era is you
know going out like you know covet and
all the things we're facing like you
can't stop that uncertainty necessarily
but can you stop your reaction to the
uncertainty and i think that's one of
the things we realize is that you
there's a lot of stuff you don't have
control over which can really affect us
but there's always one thing you do have
control over which is your own attitude
which is your own behavior and as you're
talking about style there's all these
techniques like marcus aurelius talked
about that you can use to kind of come
to acceptance on that um one of my
favorite ones is a technique uh called
rain this has been popularized by a
meditation teacher named tara brock and
it's a technique you can use whenever
you're feeling a negative emotion the
acronym reigns stands for
are recognized like oh this is sadness
this is frustration i'm mad at my
parents this is fear about college like
this is stress
recognize what it is then allow it like
okay you're cool you can be here like
it's like a bad dinner guest or like a
bad person who showed up at your house
you don't kick them out but you just
allow it they're just going to be there
and they're going to go and you i
investigate like what does it feel like
in my body get that kind of bodily
awareness
and then you do the end which i think
you know people who study at khan
academy struggle with and the end is
nurture which is like the
self-compassion this is not going to
help you to beat yourself up so what can
you do to nurture yourself like it sucks
to feel uncertain or frustrated or sad
or scared or whatever you're feeling
what can you do to be nice to yourself
not in a like again i'm going to blow
everything off and watch netflix or like
you know scroll on reddit what can you
do to be really nutritiously nice for
yourself what do you actually need right
now
and so that practice is one that i use
myself especially a lot of in the covid
time when there's a lot of uncertainty
and scary stuff happening like recognize
like oh this sucks but i can be with it
and investigate and kind of nurture it
and this is exactly what the stoics like
marcus aurelius were talking about you
can't control the outside world but you
can control your reaction to it
and just touching on that same idea this
question here from facebook gisella
padilla bovino
i mean you've touched on this and i'll
expand her question a little bit she's
asking what other micro habits do you
suggest for everyday well-being i'll
extend it and this conversation's gone
way faster the more i enjoy it the
faster it goes uh
you know i i i know what other micro
habits i think we're all looking for
these these these very um insightful
i mean call them hacks call them
whatever you want but they're micro
habits but i'm also curious about your
day like make it tangible for us i mean
you're you're
by external
observer you're a professor at yale
seems like a stressful job you you have
a lot of responsibilities how do you
give us a day of your life and how you
manage these things
yeah well you said some of them
meditation is huge um gratitude i really
just i have like a little notes thing on
my phone where i just try to write
things down
another new one that i think can be
really powerful students is
making good use of what's called time
confetti so i mentioned that we're all
feeling more time famished but we
actually have more time like that's a
disconnect what's up uh what's up is
that we have more time but it's broken
up into these tiny little chunks this is
what researcher ashley williams calls
time confetti right like little pieces
here and there and it can feel like oh i
don't have that much time i have five
minutes like i'll just scroll on social
media or i'll do something stupid i'll
get like a little dopamine reward hit
but not achieve anything real for my
like nutritious healthiness um ashley
williams suggests making what she calls
a time confetti list like when you have
that five minutes here and there what
can you really do with it again not
school work like what can you do with it
to connect with a friend or have a like
good moment with your family or
experience some gratitude or just do
those deep breaths that i mentioned um
and so this is a technique i've stolen
from ashley i actually have a list of my
time confetti list and it's hard you
know if this is if this call ends a
little early i'll look at i'll be like
oh i'll check my email or i'll do i'll
you know scroll on write or something
it's like nope i look at my time
confetti list and i'm like oh i should
text a friend or oh i should set up that
coffee date for the future that i've
been putting off right like what what
are things that you can do nutritiously
for your well-being not just like blow
off the time then you'll kind of feel
like you're a little less time famished
and that can do wonders for your
well-being
i love that i love that term time
confetti because now that you've named
it i'm like yeah there's tons of time
confetti all over the place you know one
thing that once i started getting into
meditation now i'm i'm almost one could
go addicted to it um you know even when
i'm in a traffic light
normally if i was at a big intersection
i'm like oh there's two two and a half
minutes of my life gone now i'm like oh
i got two and a half minutes of now i'll
call it time confetti and i'll you know
i don't close my eyes because i need to
pay attention to the light but i'll say
i'm just going to look at this very
meditative red light and just breathe
deeply and then like i'm like oh it's
over i gotta go all right
but i love that and you can text one
last question because we've been kind of
talking about it on the margin you just
alluded to it
you know a lot of people are talking
about social media even in the recent
trends you know we've had people like
jonathan hate on this live stream talk
about he seems to to point the finger at
social media being a reason
why especially this generation of young
people who grew up on social media seem
especially uh prone to anxiety or or
depression
are there some
rules that you would you recommend even
that you're practicing yourself or that
you would want to do with your you know
the students you work with or your
family yeah i think i think the rule
that i use a lot and i suggest a lot to
my students is to kind of mindfully pay
attention to what feels nutritious this
is hard right our brains are telling us
to go after the wrong stuff and this is
natural selection's fault right like you
know when i'm having a bad day i'm like
cupcake you know like go inward and sit
and plop down and watch netflix turns
out those things will not nutritiously
feel good for my well-being like calling
a friend doing something active trying
to learn something new you know those
actually are positive forms of leisure
that will make me feel better problem is
your brain doesn't notice it it leads
you the wrong way and so mindfulness can
help here right and part of me actually
just literally takes a view of like when
i'm done an activity think about like
what did that feel like was that
nutritious was that good like do i feel
yucky now and then that causes your
brain like the loop that forms habits
can notice like wait hang on that wasn't
rewarding in a like really nutritious
way maybe i shouldn't do that anymore
you know so when you're done you know
social media whatever it was take a
moment to notice like how'd that feel do
i feel great now do i feel crummy do i
feel kind of more apathetic same with
like tv sometimes right like you know
there's good tv and positive tv where
you can learn but then there's sometimes
it just makes you feel kind of gross and
apathetic notice that and then notice
the opposite like when i called a friend
or tried to learn something new or did
that big deep breath or did that 10
minutes of meditation how did that make
me feel exercise is another big one
right you know do like 10 minutes of
just like hit in your you know in your
room or grab like a quick youtube like
exercise class how do you feel
afterwards problem is we're so busy we
don't notice our own rewards you know we
just assume like oh yeah that scrolling
on social media things felt awesome and
we don't take the time to be like no it
didn't it actually felt kind of crummy
like it was an easy thing to do you know
it's a very low startup cost but
afterwards i just don't feel great but
but you need to do that like two seconds
of your time confetti to take time to
notice what's feeling good and that can
kind of steer you in the right direction
no well this was a super interesting
conversation i could talk for for many
many more hours i hope we get more
chances to discuss this
but but thank you so much lori this this
was hopefully very helpful and hope
brings a lot of people on this journey
to having a healthier happier life
thanks so much for having me on this is
great
well thanks everyone for joining uh
hopefully you enjoyed that as much as i
did i definitely am going to tweak a
little bit of my time confetti although
i have to say i'm you know not to get
you know half of my meditation is to
kind of disassociate myself from my my
ego and my identity but uh so uh you
know over the last several years
probably been induced by stress i have
as i've told many of y'all doing a lot
more meditation it's been a game changer
for me so i'm gonna underline everything
that lori just said
if you're really daring think about cold
showers you can read up about them
they're a little bit painful going in
but as laurie said when you're done you
feel great and actually you'll save time
because your your showers will be
shorter um
but don't do it if you're sick i don't
want to you know people get in trouble
if someone gets a cold or something like
that um and yeah and physical activity
you know one thing i've been trying to
do when possible when i'm on zoom or
anything like that i try to go for a
walk uh and tell i tell people like hey
i'm gonna turn the camera off go for a
walk i want some fresh air i want to
walk around get my blood flowing and
these have been the type of uh a life
hacks and everything that lori just
mentioned you know gratitude i just got
feedback and at work that you know i'm
not thanking people enough and i was
like how did i become that grumpy person
who doesn't thank people and over the
last week i've been trying to thank
people more and lori's right it
it makes you happy uh and i'll just
remind everyone again what laurie said
by donating doing good for for others
it'll make you happy so that's going to
be my new uh pitch when i ask for
philanthropic donations for khan academy
uh so with that thanks everyone i'll see
you on tuesday where we'll do a ask me
anything uh have a great weekend
you